according to research by economist  America has more low-paying jobs than  any other developed country in the world  that's the new statistic yeah now out of  34 nations surveyed including Italy  Japan and Greece none had a higher  percentage of low-paying jobs than our  country do you realize what this means  ladies and gentlemen USA is number one  [Applause]  some Americas low-paid heroes there's  many a Quiznos sandwich maker who's $8  an hour there's Barbara a public  schoolteacher had to take a second job  selling bootleg fireworks  there's Tami a Holiday Inn Express  prostitute who rakes in 38 99 tonight  plus free shower gel and conditioner  Ethan is a Huffington Post blogger who  earns about 650 every time he poses  celebrity nip-slip Oliver is a homeland  security agent trying to get a better  paying job at Quiznos and Andy is a talk  show  [Applause]  fabulous  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you